let's look in detail at what food technology does for us
technology
how flash pasteurization improves
food shelf life and
protects against harmful bacteria
food technology allows us to
replace the air inside the
package to preserve flavor and
natural composition and color
additional antioxidants keep
food as fresh as possible and for as long as
possible
while protecting it from spoilage and keeping it
in the best quality in our homes
we can benefit from the use of
environmentally friendly refrigerators which not only
keep food fresh but use much
less energy in the process
in short food technology
allows us to avoid this and keep
this food technology in
europe meets the highest standards of
control to protect us keep
food fresh and tasty and keep
the economy strong food technology for
better food